this is a puzzle proposed to me by a
viewer in the comments of one of my last
videos say you're given two envelopes
and told that both have money inside but
one has two times as much money as the
other you can keep one of them you pick
one at random but just before you open
it you decide to do a little calculation
to check whether this was the right
choice or whether you should swap you
say the amount of money in the envelope
you have is some unknown X then let's
figure out what the expected value is of
the amount in the other envelope well
it's either 1/2 X or 2x and both are
equally likely so the expectation value
should be this but that's bigger than X
as in in expectation the other envelope
has more money than the one you
currently have and so you should switch
obviously this is wrong
both envelopes are equally likely to
contain the higher amount the point of
this puzzle isn't for you to prove that
to me what I want you to do is explain
why this reasoning went wrong see this
is what we call a fallacy when you have
reasoning that seems correct but gives
you a false result as opposed to a
paradox which has correct reasoning but
leads to a seemingly impossible result
which is actually correct anyway I think
I have one way of explaining what went
wrong but I'd be interested in seeing
what you guys say and see if you have a
different solution to me